coming up this weekend at UNLV the
return of the high school jazz band
Festival known as essentially Ellington
put on with the Jazz Outreach initiative
with us this morning one of the founders
of Joy Kenny rampton hey Kenny thank you
so much for being here and executive
director Donnie Thompson so Donnie in
addition to the jazz festival we want to
do something special this morning
because there are a lot of programs that
donate musical instruments but we have a
Twist here this is the first of its kind
that we're aware of that we actually
also give away courtesy of the donors
that come to us a Year's worth of free
private music lessons so in addition to
the instruments that get donated a lot
of them come from music and arts the
largest instrument retailer in the
country they donate instruments our
donors kick in the money for the lessons
but occasionally we get somebody such as
yourself today who has a great looking
instrument that actually is ready to
play as well and they donate the
instrument we find a student that is
worthy of learning that instrument we
provide the lessons and the instrument
and it's just a wonderful way to to
start the day today with you yeah so our
son has moved on from the drums so we
are proud to donate and let's introduce
Christina Bates director of band at
Courtney High nice to see you it's been
years since we saw it and here's what
grade are you in I'm in eighth grade
eighth grader uh Christian hey Christian
nice to see you and the assistant
principal thank you chalice Johnson from
Courtney thank you guys for being here
so uh Christian how long have you been
playing drums I've been playing around
four years now since I was 10. okay so
we have a certificate and everything to
make this official don't we this is the
certificate for years worth of free
private newslet lessons from donors in
our community and Christian on behalf of
myself and it's an honor to donate this
drum kit to you and here are your sticks
congratulations so
I don't know if you can sit down and
bang anything up but while you're doing
that Kenny tell us real quickly about
the essentially Ellington thing this is
high school jazz bands from all over the
West right yeah we've got several coming
in from California and from the Las
Vegas community and we've got incredible
special guests come enough to educate
the kids Todd Stoll from Jazzy Lincoln
Center I'm head of our education
department in in New York we've got
Rodney Whitaker we've got Dave Lowe
we've got Camille Thurman Jeff Hamilton
one of the world's greatest jazz
drummers
um so it's it's all starting tonight
really and there's a Saturday night
concert but Christian won't be playing
there but can you play us out just for a
little bit there son
on your new drums go ahead just rip
something away because congratulations
on getting your drum set here and the
drum lessons from the Jazz Outreach
initiative Donnie thank you so much
absolutely and real quick we want to
give you this official uh t-shirt for
the essentially Ellington Festival we
thank you for being a part of it as well
as awesome and
um by the way anyone that goes on uh to
our website jazzoutreach initiative.org
and signs up for our e-newsletter we are
going to give away two pairs of all
access passes to the festival and the
free concert all right Christian take us
out man
[Music]
thank you very soon